let's just bring you some breaking news
now and debris from the Titan
submersible which was recovered from the
ocean floor near the wreck of the
Titanic has been brought back to shore
let's show these images you can see that
they show the remains of the vessel
being unloaded from the ship the Horizon
Arctic at the Canadian Coast Guard pier
in Saint John's in Newfoundland so those
images there of the Titan submersible
wreckage being recovered from the depths
of the Atlantic Ocean you can see their
Crews pulling those pieces of the Saab
from the waters and off the ship there
um more than a week after it's imploded
it imploded a course around 13 000 feet
underwater close to the wreckage of the
Titanic uh killing all five men on board
and
now an international group of agencies
is investigating what may have caused
that implosion with U.S Maritime
officials saying that they're going to
issue a report aimed at improving the
safety of submersibles worldwide so
those latest images there of the titans
of submersible are being taken off that
ship in Newfoundland